Now that you're experts on properties,
let's go back to methods for a moment
and think a little more carefully about
the syntax of how methods are called.
I've initialized the movies here, so
we can have a movie archive object
devoted to Rob Reiner movies.
You've already seen
a call to filterByYear.
Here it is one more time.
We just use .syntax on an instance
of the MovieArchive class, and
then we call filterByYear and
pass in the year we want to filter by.
Let's go with 1986.
And then, we'll want to grab
the first item from our movies array,
Print out the title and
we can see that it's Stand By Me.
filterByYear is an instance method.
You may also have occasion to call
type methods or class methods.
Type methods, like type properties,
belong to the class, not to any
particular instance of the class.
And so, they're called on the class
instead of being called on
an instance of the class.
You're going to run into a number of
type methods when you start working with
the iOs user interface library.
UIKit.
For example,
here's a class method that you'll use
when you build the second portfolio app.
Me me.
This method belongs to
the UIImagePickerController class.
It's called is SourceTypeAvailable.
It takes in a source type as an argument
and returns a bool indicating whether
that source type is available
on the current device.
A source type, in this case, is
the source of an image, like a camera or
a photo album.
In the playground,
there's no camera available.
So in the playground environment,
if you pass in source type camera,
this method returns false.
The playground does have access
to the photo library, so
if you pass in source type photo
library, the method returns true.
If you are running this code
on a phone with a camera,
this method would return true for
both source types.
Let's take a look at the class
definition for UIImagePickerController.
I can access it from the playground by
command clicking on the class name.
Now, this might look intimidating.
But all it is a list of properties and
methods.
Right here is the method
isSourceTypeAvailable.
Notice that it has the word
class before func.
Just like type properties.
Type method definitions begin
with the word class or static.
Otherwise, they're defined
just like instance methods.
And if you use the word
class instead of static,
subclasses will be able
to override the method.